Richard Justus joining us on the program
to discuss what did you think of the
penalty handed out by Major League
Baseball Richard I sort of agree with
you I thought Jeff Luna was going to get
a lifetime ban when you factor in that
this sign stealing plus the behavior in
the wake of the assistant GM yelling at
the female reporters which they just
handled this gracefully but everything
is connected to every other little thing
and I think the Commissioner thought
handing down the harshest penalty ever
sent a message you know after the Apple
watch incident in the Red Sox dugout in
2017
he had told teams if this happens again
is going to be really bad who blew the
whistle Mike fiers in the athletic and
Ken Rosenthal and Evan dry like fake
glue they blew the whistle without some
without the journalism this probably
doesn't happen without one player you
know during the ALCS AJ Hinch stood up
and said hey come on if you got
something against us put your name on it
well Mike fiers put his name on it do
you think he'll be blackballed fires you
know I have heard that there's been a
lot of discussion about but among the
baseball writers and talking to players
like the guy did reveal secrets and
that's for 125 years been something you
didn't do so we'll see about that there
are going to be people that probably
look at him a different way but I don't
think that should I don't think that
should influence how people see what the
Astros did in any different light you
know they they they cheated and people
will say did Dan you hear people say
well you have all this technology now
it's too tempting look this was no gray
area they knew what they were doing walk
me through the system and give me the
part that is the actual cheating the
cheating is using electronics to cheat
yeah you know guys that you and I both
knew like Tony Gwynn and Frank Robinson
they headed this intuitive ability to
detect sign ceiling what happened when
in MLB instituted replay they put
monitors near every dugout so teams
could so AJ
could say do I need to read I need to
challenge that call
well what Alex Cora and others said look
if we've got the signs being relayed by
the catcher right here behind our dugout
why don't we study them and come up with
the sequencing and then and look I heard
from an Al West team but this they've
been whispering about this for years I
don't want to reveal the team but they
may play in Oakland California and and
they heard all the stuff the banging of
the trash cans I didn't hear about the
whistle but like a 1 bang for a
curveball two bangs for a changeup no
bang fastball and believe me people in
the game that what difference does that
make
it makes all the difference in the world
because the the pitcher holds the
control controlled by the sequencing of
the pitching if you know the pitchers
coming it is a huge huge advantage so
they would they would monitor the signs
they would figure out the signs and then
relay at some wave of bayon or trash can
Alex wood of the Dodgers pitched a great
game for in 22 20 17 World Series they
first became alerted because the Astros
were changing signs and games wanted to
a Dodger Stadium they it was like oh
they think we're doing it that means
they must be doing until in that game
game for Alex wood and and the catcher
changed the signs every 12 pitches the
Nationals came into the World Series
games in Houston and we actually if you
saw there were times the the pitcher
took his hat off and looked inside they
had a code board also I think maybe you
noticed it may he didn't notice I don't
believe Fox Sports during the World
Series showed catchers dropping science
and I think that's a first so I know
they're obviously with some suspicion
that things were going on and the
monitors they had to put my him up he
had to put Hall monitors by the people
with the switch with it with it with the
screens and told them in Houston be on
the alert for science for whistles for
calling a player by a lastname firstname
trash cans all of that stuff would you
be keep the title I don't think you can
do that you know the one thing they did
you can
and what yeah you can do it but look you
don't have to do it the title in so many
ways has been vacated and Dan that look
I live in Houston fifty-six years this
was the city that watched other teams
celebrate and in the wake of the
hurricane Harvey and how the city
rallied around the team and the team
rallied around the city and how the joy
that that team played with it was like
you would see people and players looking
at the World Series trophy like keep an
eye on that because they're going to
take that away and give it to Boston
because that's what is always happened
in Houston and now you can say okay we
cleaned house in the progress we're
going to start over here we're gonna
gonna have a new day what about the
clubhouse how do you write a story about
the Astros now without mentioning it
because everything you've accomplished
comes back to that where they're fair or
not whether any player where their
players used it or players didn't use it
and the report says most of the players
of the 2017 team did use it I mean I
think it might have said virtually all
the players so in so many ways the title
has been vacated
what's worse what Pete Rose did or with
the institution it's pretty much the
same in that I think that's why the
Commissioner came out hard because when
you went to watch the Reds play when
Pete was managing did he have money bet
on that game did he not have money bet
on that game did an impact the way he
managed the bullpen in that game you
don't know that but the suspicion means
maybe the game isn't on the up-and-up
and when you go to a game I think this
is like Rob Manfred was was focused on
is like you want to make sure both teams
are playing by the same rules we're
talking to Richard justice mlb.com
national writer what did the Red Sox do
what is baseball do to the Red Sox
they're gonna kill them at me and
they're gonna it's not going to be any
different you know Rob Manfred said that
this was the most thorough investigation
the investigation the Astros the most
thorough baseball of every done I think
68 witnesses and eighty thousand emails
something like that the Red Sox are
gonna get the same treatment and like
you I think you used the word mastermind
in terms of Alex Cora he's gonna get
hammered
but then what did the Red Sox do are the
Red Sox base their punishment off what
the Astros did with
is Alex who are gonna get fired I would
think so but that's that's going to be
an ownership call for the Red Sox but
there is that peer pressure now look are
you going to give your you're going to
let your guy walk when the guys that
wear this the ground zero of the scandal
they threw the they threw the guys out
in the street
there certainly is going to be that and
I think the first paragraph of Peter
Abraham's doing the Boston Globe is
today is something like the Red Sox are
going to be under increasing pressure to
fire Alex core that that's not beating
around the bush there but also you have
Carlos Beltran who as a player was
involved in this with the Astros now
he's the manager of the Mets so can you
punish him now as a manager whereas it
feels like the players aren't being
punished because that Union is so
powerful and baseball may not want to
take them on or am I reading too much
into this I think the decision early on
was we're gonna give the players
immunity we want to know the story tell
us what happened here and I think in 17
when Rob Manfred Na I believe he said
this in meetings with general managers
and managers and sent a memo to all
clubs to the ownership on down like the
people in charge are going to be held
accountable if you start saying okay I'm
not view this player and do this play
role first of all you're probably going
to end up suspended every player on the
2017 Astros because it appears that some
they they benefited in some way or other
so well that's a fine distinction Carlos
Beltran was a player on that team
obviously you know he he was invited to
appears to have been involved deal let
him skate I would think you know it's
just one that he's a rookie manager he
removed from playing this is just one
more thing he's going to have to answer
to you know you thought you were going
to have headaches Carlos you got more
headaches than you thought you were
going to have how would you feel if
you're a Dodger fan or a Yankee fan
today
well like Clayton Kershaw said um about
a month ago when this came out ask him
about it Neal well well it it sucks I
mean that is such and you can't you know
you can't you can't replay it but there
you know Bill Pulaski wrote today they
got to vacate the tile and give it to
the Dodgers I don't think that's gonna I
don't
to the Dodgers you can vacate it but you
don't give up to the Dodgers but it but
it does stink because when you go back
and look at game 5 replaying Game five
of the World Series when the craziest
games ever played there were pitches
that were hit in that game you go oh my
god that guy looked like he knew the
ball knew what pitch there was he was
sitting on a breaking ball which doesn't
happen in so it calls into question
everything and if you're the Dodgers you
go that's not fair and you know the side
stories that Dave Roberts the manager of
the Dodgers and AJ Hinch I don't know if
they're best friends but they're very
very close and that's four that's gonna
make for an odd Christmas card exchanger
and it's not over yet because you know I
don't think I think well here's the
problem Dan it's not gonna be over
because everything what if George
Springer is hitting 215 on July 1 how
that shows you what if the Astros are 20
and 20 you know oh you can't do it
fairly you can't play on this you you
open the door
that it's going to be a long time
closing but in also if you start out 20
and 5 and then people say the Astros can
say we didn't need to cheat to be great
they better beat 20 and 5 would be a
very good way to turn the page on this
thing you want to turn the page when one
hundred and eight-seven games again and
win the World Series and then people say
oh you come up with something new
how are you cheating now hey Richard
great to talk to you we appreciate your
time as always
thank you Dan that's Richard justice
mlb.com national writer for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on be our live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]